this is a watershed moment for our union  [Music]  we will do everything we can  to help ukrainians prevail and retake  the future into their hands  russia is blackmailing us  we see energy prices breaking record  after record  the consequences for households and  companies are not sustainable anymore we  the commission are now working on an  emergency intervention  and a structural reform of the  electricity market  we have to get rid of the dependency on  russian fossil fuels  with our we power eu initiative  we will invest together 300 billion  euros to accelerate the green transition  nusutional economy  if we act in unity  we can address any crisis